so it's black friday we're going to do
some movie previews because there's a
lot of big movies coming out end of the
year some i'm kind of excited about some
not so much so first up west side story
comes out december 10th here's a little
bit of the teaser
[Music]
life matters
even more than love
[Music]
steven spielberg is remaking this movie
this is a bad idea so the original
musical which is maybe the greatest
musical ever written there are really
only a few contenders for that it's
south pacific by rogers and hammerstein
and west side story which is kind of an
agglomeration of the greatest talents in
every area of theater you have arthur
lorenz who who did the libretto and you
have stephen sondheim writing the lyrics
you have leonard bernstein writing the
music you have jordan robbins doing the
choreography right it really is kind of
a meeting of all of the greats and the
the original musical on broadway
actually did not blow things out it
didn't really explode on broadway but
the musical which is directed by robert
wise that one won like all the awards
including best picture so now they're
remaking it i don't really see any
reason to do so because the original
movie is quite good and the original
movie did something that they used to do
back in the day which is make sure that
everyone could sing and if you couldn't
sing they would voice you over so
natalie wood could not sing there's very
famously some tape of natalie wood
trying to sing maria and it doesn't go
great
and so they voice her over using marty
nixon
[Music]
who voiced over everyone in those days
like you can hear marnie nixon voicing
over everyone from deborah carr in the
king and i to natalie wood to ri moreno
she actually is singing with herself
marnie nixon she's singing natalie wood
and rina moreno in the same film the
movie's great it's a it's a really
really good movie and now they're
remaking it i really don't understand
why i don't really get it i'm trying to
remember the last time a classic movie
was remade and everybody was like that
was great remember they did a
shot-for-shot remake of psycho it was
just this total fail i kind of have the
same feeling about this one because
everybody knows west side story
everybody did west side story in high
school so it's not like we're taking a
forgotten gem and then remaking it we're
taking a movie that won best picture
remaking it after everybody has seen the
musical it's like remaking sound of
music today like why would you why would
you do that i'm not even a sound music
fan but why would there's just no way to
do it i guess that the star is ansel
elgort the guy from baby driver and
apparently he can sing we are told that
everybody else is sort of a newbie
apparently some of them can sing
apparently they all can dance i would
certainly hope so my greatest nightmare
is that they do west side story up in
the same way that they did sweeney todd
where they had johnny depp who could not
sing singing sweeney todd helena bonham
carter who cannot sing doing mrs lovett
or do it like la la land where you have
two main characters who cannot sing and
cannot dance in a musical so it doesn't
sound like they're doing that for west
side story but suffice it to say i i
remain skeptical that the new west side
story is going to be worth the wait
alrighty next nightmare ellie from
guillermo del toro it comes out december
17th here's what that trailer looks like
you know people stand
they fool themselves
i've given you a fortune it's time that
you delivered
when does it end
i want to know
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
[Music]
now i got to admit i'm not the biggest
guillermo del toro fan i really didn't
like pan's labyrinth people were very
fascinated with that stuff i was not
super into it this looks good uh so
bradley cooper and you have cate
blanchett you have tony collette like
that's a big cast and it's rooted in a
1946 novel it was made into a 1947 movie
with tyrone power it's literally
unavailable anywhere there are a lot of
film noir fans who really consider
nightmare ally to be like one of the
great film noirs and you can't find it
anywhere you have to buy it on dvd i
think and nobody has a dvd player
anymore so it's not streaming anymore
which is very frustrating but the
original movie is quite good it's a
bradley cooper in the in the tyrone
power part i'm very into anything that's
kind of throwback and suspends creepy
throwback stuff i'm i'm into it i i kind
of like this i should have known you
with that kind of
it takes one to catch one all righty
spiderman is out that same date december
17th spiderman no way home here's a
little bit of the trailer peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
i have a feeling this is gonna be a
massive disappointment the reason i
think it's gonna be a massive
disappointment is i feel like that
spider-man
arc is now running its course they went
so light with tom holland and and now
they're kind of stuck because the
original spider-man toby mcguire which
is now kind of an underrated film
had like an undercurrent of a little bit
more seriousness to it because it was
sam raimi
and the new spider-man is really so
unbelievably light it's kind of cotton
candy
and so in an attempt to give a gravitas
they're bringing back in all of the old
spider-man characters right they're
bringing back pretty obviously the green
goblin they're bringing back doc ock
they're bringing back all of the people
from the old spider-man movies and
whenever you have a new series that
starts to rely on nostalgia for the old
series there's really only two ways to
deal with it one is to actually ensconce
yourself in that world recognize that
the new world is not as cool as the old
world and then just deal with it
disappointed
and the other way to do it is to
cannibalize the old world for the new
world that is the force awakens style
you take all of these great legacy
characters who used to love and then you
just murder them in order to service a
bunch of secondary characters you don't
care as much about and i have a feeling
that's the way that spider-man no way
home is going to go if this doesn't
actually end with all of these
spider-men pointing at one another
wearing their spiderman outfits like the
meme then i feel like we've all missed
out and the movie wasn't worth it we'll
get some more on this in just one second
first i got my parents like one of the
best gifts i've ever gotten them a
couple of years ago i used legacy box
what is legacy box what my parents out
in their garage they had a bunch of old
film reels they had a bunch of vhs tapes
bunch of old pictures unless it was just
kind of muldering out there and every
time it would rain you'd think oh is
there going to be a leak is it going to
ruin all of their memories so i went
over to their house took all that stuff
dumped it in the legacy box sent it to
legacy box and it came back all
digitized and preserved forever you can
do the same thing send your legacy box
filled with old home movies and pictures
they'll do the rest digitizing your
moments onto a thumb drive the cloud or
dvd it's like magic if you're like most
people there's one box you'd run back
into your burning house to grab is the
box filled with all those old memories
but here's the thing it's better if
they're digitized so why not use legacy
box go check out legacy box right now
each item is hand digitized by a team of
over 200 trained technicians right here
in the united states that will keep you
informed every step of the way and
they've been used by over a million
people it's easy it's safe you're gonna
get back a great gift for yourself for
your parents you'll be preserving
something truly worthwhile today is the
day take advantage of legacy box's black
friday event visit legacybox.com shapiro
to save an unreal 65
with limited quantities ready to ship
the steel will go fast that is
legacybox.com shapiro for legacy box's
lowest prices of the year legacybox.com
shapiro december 22nd the matrix
resurrections comes out so old keanu
reeves doing old keanu reeves stuff
here's a bit of the trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix why
just why i don't understand why so the
first matrix is a good interesting film
and the other matrix is don't exist
so the new matrix basically looks like
the same plot of the matrix except that
keanu reeves is older so they made him
forget and now he's gonna have to get
back in the matrix that seems like the
plot of the film and i gotta tell ya i'm
not super into it again we're going back
to the well too many times on these
ideas the watkowski what are they
sisters now have they made anything
remotely resembling a good movie in 25
years i am unaware if they have ain't no
blade can protect you from the true
truth and so i have very little faith
that this will be a an excellent piece
of filmmaking listen i love keanu reeves
i'll now watch tiana reeves in anything
but triple kick yeah
how about just like endless john wick
and no more matrix
that same day december 22nd the king's
man which is a kingsman sequel comes out
here's what the trailer looks like
[Applause]
i'm gonna love calling you
[Music]
we shall see
the king's man which is directed by
matthew vaughn who did kick ass as well
as the kingsmen movies he is back and
now he is going for the sequel prequel
thing so i'll admit that i was amused by
the first kingsmen the second one is
really not good at all and so the king's
man
which looks like just kind of another
fantasy
spy caper but set in what what kind of
looks like
the end of of world war one britain and
russia is that character supposed to be
rasputin i assume so first of all no
colin firth means that it is immediately
a worse movie second of all ray fines is
only playing m now apparently ray finds
just m and everything so that's too bad
i don't know that there was high demand
for a prequel to king's men but i guess
they're going to try and spin this off
into into an entire world
i just i got to tell you i'm rather
uninterested in it i can't i think a lot
of the the original shock of king's men
is that it was supposed to be james bond
but with actual exploding heads and a
sort of satirical take on james bond and
then they moved so far down that road
that there was nothing left elton just
calmed down
and so it looks like they're trying to
recapitulate this as a less head
exploding exercise and i'm not sure that
it's going to work it looks almost like
a marvel version of king's men
december 24th it's a pick me up don't
look up by adam mckay all about an
asteroid hitting earth just in time for
christmas here's a bit of the trailer
this could be a complete disaster this
is already a disaster
you know that girl from live tv said
we're all gonna die now
[Applause]
you'll never take me alive
there it is
a giant comet hurtling its way
towards earth can you see it
i can't my letter's gonna back
all righty so then there's don't look up
by the wildly overrated adam mckay i do
not like adam mckay's films i think that
they are stylized trash i think that he
has a horrible view on politics i
thought that vice was almost in a weird
way like a hate watch for conservatives
where dick cheney becomes the the
anti-hero
i i didn't like big short i just i think
adam mckay is an ignoramus pretending
that he knows things and slickly
packaging his ignorance in his films so
his new movie is don't look up it is
co-written by adam mckay and by david
sirota david sirota is a kind of crazy
person he used to be an editor at
jacobin he's a speechwriter for bernie
sanders in 2019 and uh david tarotta is
a guy who wrote a piece i kid you not
titled after the boston marathon bombing
let's hope the boston marathon bomber is
a white guy i'm not kidding that's an
actual piece that he wrote he also wrote
a piece about hugo chavez's economic
miracle in 2013. and so now he has
failed up to writing a mainstream
hollywood flick with adam mckay and when
i say writing i mean that the typical
story on adam mckay apparently is that
he basically writes the bare bones of
scenes then he has the actor's improv
so depending on the improv skills of the
actors it can be funny if however the
actors are not good at improv which many
actors are not then probably it's it's
not all all that funny the basic plot of
the film is giant asteroid about to hit
earth entire government infrastructure
ignoring asteroid about hit earth
leonardo dicaprio naturally says that
this is a metaphor for global warming
huge cast it's jennifer lawrence and
leonardo dicaprio and meryl streep
playing meryl streep because she's meryl
streep in every film now ariana grande
fresh from licking donuts at the local
shop ron perlman mark rylance tyler
perry what did you guys get a group rate
or something is timothy chalamet is
there now like a a contractual
obligation for every film to have
timothy chalyman i'll just be honest
with you i don't get the timothy
challenge i don't think he's a terrible
actor i just don't think he's like god's
gift to acting i think he's the worst
thing in the king he is one of the
weaker elements of dune i've never seen
a timothy chalamet film except for maybe
ladybird where i thought he's really
good in it and then later but it felt
like he was just playing timothy
chalamet i for the life of me don't
understand why he's in every single film
that is made now with that said big cast
this is what adam mckay does he puts
together these all-star casts to do
basically political films that make
everybody feel good about themselves and
earn no money at the box office this
will probably do a little better because
at least it's not just an overt i hate
george w bush movie now it's sort of a
covert i hate everybody who doesn't
believe like me that we should destroy
the entire economy of the western world
in order to prevent the seas from rising
afoot over the course of the next 100
years instead of just building some sea
walls alrighty we'll get to more movie
previews in just one second first you
really want to impress that special
someone this holiday season give them
the gift of comfort i'm talking about
the x chair i love my exterior it is the
most comfortable and ergonomic chair
i've ever used honestly it's the coolest
looking piece of furniture i own it's
like your captain kirk sitting on the
bridge or something what makes extra the
world's greatest office chair maybe it's
the patented dynamic variable lumbar
support or the fact you can add lmax
technology with four massage options and
the ability to warm or cool your bath
not a lot of other office chairs can do
that as in none now is the perfect time
to purchase an ex-chair why now because
now is the only time extra goes on sale
all year that's right they only have a
black friday cyber monday weekend that's
it you deserve a next chair and you're
going to kick yourself if you missed
this special deal save up to 500 bucks
on xchair there are four days only where
this deal is available on black friday
cyber monday weekend go to
exchairshapiro.com right now that's
letter x chair s-h-a-p-i-r-o dot com
extra has a 30-day guarantee of complete
comfort you can finance your purchase
for as little as 25 bucks a month go to
ex-chair shapiro.com save up to 500
bucks xchairshapiro.com
and finally on christmas day the
appropriately timed american underdog
kurt warner story here's what the
trailer looks like
kurt warner out of the arena league it's
one of those stories that's too good for
the movies the perfect guy here he was
bagging groceries five years ago
go out there and you show the world what
i've known all along
[Applause]
this is my time i know who i am and i
know why i'm here
that's a movie about kurt warner the
former st louis rams quarterback who
literally was stocking shelves when he
was discovered and he played some arena
football and then he ended up in the nfl
and he won the mvp a couple of times
really great quarterback uh and happens
to be a conservative christian so that's
what the film is about this looks like
something like nice to take the kids to
it's nice to see a movie that i can take
the kids to naturally the critics will
hate it because it stars zach levi and
because it is about a conservative
christian and because the directors of
the movie made i can only imagine which
is another christian flick so they'll
hate this one as well but honestly it
looks like good clean wholesome fun is
it like top of my movie watching list is
it like number one in my holiday that's
probably not but it's definitely
something that i could see
watching with the wife and and maybe
with the kids so pretty
pretty good all righty so there's your
holiday movie preview i'll tell you how
all these movies were after i actually
see them we'll check back in then
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe